the united states national debt has now
officially crossed 30 trillion dollars
this is absolute banana land what the
hell is going on the u.s debt yesterday
officially crossing that 30 trillion
dollar mark a nice round number that is
so big that most people could even count
to it if they tried now who the hell do
we owe 30 trillion dollars to well that
increase of 7 trillion since just 2019
is due to the undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy literally people are
spending as if they are drunken sailors
eight trillion of it is owed to foreign
investors japan and china some of the
top creditors and not only do we have to
repay that eight trillion dollars but we
gotta pay them back the principal plus
interest and then six trillion my
favorite part six trillion dollars of
our 30 trillion dollar national debt is
the government owing money to the
government that's right six trillion
dollars is the u.s government owing the
money to themselves absolute insanity
now if we go ahead and we look at
actually what's been going on you can go
all the way back to 1981 that was the
first time we crossed over and owed one
trillion dollars in the national debt it
took us from 1981 until 1986 five years
to get to two trillion dollars in the
debt of the united states then from 1986
all the way till 1992 to double again
and so we were doubling every five or
six years but somehow someway since 2008
things have gone absolutely insane since
2008 we've gone from 10 trillion in
national debt to now 30 trillion just
about 14 years later and so when you
start to look at these numbers what you
can realize is that we are continuing to
absolutely spend more than we make we're
having to borrow more and more money in
order to pay off past debts this is
unsustainable if you look at the us
national debt as a percent of gdp what
you can see is that we started out in
the 80s at 31
by 2000 we had crossed over 50 and we're
staying there pretty sustainably from
1990 all the way through about 2005 and
then things got absolute bonkers and
took off and today we have national debt
125
of gdp if we go ahead and we take a look
at the actual growth and we say to
ourselves what is going on here the u.s
national debt increasing at 8.6 percent
per year over the last 15 years but u.s
economic growth that nominal gdp number
only growing at 3.6
per year obviously if we're borrowing
faster than we're growing that's not
good my friends that's actually a really
bad thing and so then we've got senator
mike lee here who says it in no
uncertain terms the national debt now is
equivalent to 90 000
per citizen if you wanted to count to 30
trillion you would have to have started
almost a million years ago
we have a national debt of 30 trillion
dollars we have no plan to be able to
balance a budget we have no plan to get
rid of this debt the united states
continues to fall further and further
behind we're borrowing money at an
insane pace we're borrowing money faster
than we're actually growing and i don't
know exactly when or how it ends but i
do know that this is absolutely
unsustainable